Сьогодні Україна воює, як одна з найкращих армій НАТО.
За вашої каденції були знищені останні десять бомбардувальників, які належали Україні.
Чи була можливість зберегти ці бомбардувальники?
Хм, підступне питання.
Цієї політики вже досить.
Щоб такого роду обструкція, як у комсомольця Орбана,
не торкалася європейського протоколу.
Носієм путінізму є не тільки Путін, а є 140 мільйонів оцих маленьких путіних.
Сьогодні говоримо з третім президентом України Віктором Ющенком.
Вікторе Андрійовичу, вітаю вас!
Про цю зустріч ми домовлялися більше двох місяців.
Наскільки мені відомо, за цей час ви встигли побувати й у закордонних відрядженнях.
Розкажіть, чим ви зараз займаєтеся?
Є політична частина, яка складається з ряду конференцій,
ряду міжнародних зустрічей, ряду високого рівня контактів, які треба для України робити.
Тому ця частина графіку є.
Що стосується домашнього графіку, він стосується в першу чергу війни.
Тому що дуже багато біди, нещасть, потреб.
Комусь треба медичну допомогу, комусь гуманітарну допомогу,
десь треба сформувати звернення:
чи то колективне, чи то індивідуальне.
Словом, зараз, як ніколи, брак часу.
Я розумію, що обов'язків у нас зараз дуже багато.
У кожного.
Щоб ти не робив - у тебе думка про фронт, про наших хлопців,
про наших дівчат і те, як наблизити день перемоги.
Ми боремося сьогодні за ті мрії, які були в наших прадідів,
дідів, а не тільки у поколінь сьогоднішніх.
І тому насправді це великий переможний бій, до якого ми готувалися добрих 300-350 років.
14 та 15 грудня на саміті у Брюсселі планують розглянути питання
про початок переговорів з Україною щодо вступу в ЄС.
Вікторе Андрійовичу, за вашої каденції було зроблено кілька важливих кроків
у напрямку євроатлантичної інтеграції.
Приміром, у військову доктрину України повернулася згадка про стратегічну мету України -
"повноправне членство в НАТО та Європейському Союзі".
Серед країн, які тоді підтримували прагнення України щодо євроатлантичної інтеграції, була й Угорщина.
Тепер же Будапешт блокує просування України на цьому шляху. Як гадаєте, чому?
Оказію, яка виникає і по словацькій, і по угорській історіям,
я сприймаю як жовту картку в футболі.
Це ще не фатально, це ще не трагедія,
але європейська сім'я починає розуміти,
що той інструментарій, який є для консолідації єдиної політики в Європі, слабкий.
Його треба змінювати, його треба доповнювати інструментами.
Щоб такого роду обструкція, як у комсомольця Орбана,
не торкалася європейського протоколу, в цьому випадку - по Україні.
Я переконаний, що це засідання, яке ми всі очікуємо,
досягне або великої домовленості у зміні процедури,
яка врешті-решт вийде на те, що голосування по Україні
не буде спиратися протокольно на всі голоси членів євросім'ї,
а коли буде заведений механізм, що конституційної більшості
членів євросім'ї буде достатньо, щоб приймати або безпекові рішення,
або оборонні рішення, або, можливо, навіть і політичні рішення.
Тобто до якоїсь міри елементи федералізації будуть впроваджені в європейський порядок,
коли не консенсусом, а більшістю голосів буде проводитися та формуватися європейська політика.
Якщо до цього дня не зміниться політика цих двох лідерів,
мені здається, що у євросім'ї є вихід тільки процедурний,
і там треба шукати відповіді.
Хочеться поговорити з вами про зміни, які нині відбуваються в Україні.
Чим ви як українець сьогодні пишаєтеся найбільше?
Найбільше я пишаюся нацією,
бо так голосно, консолідовано, так одним голосом ми ще ніколи не говорили.
Нас намагалися розтягти, що ми різні, що є Захід і Схід,
що є російськомовні, є українці, є російська церква, є українська, є культура й так далі.
Я сказав би, що політика девальвації всього українського,
яка особливо жорстокою була у ХХ столітті,
коли нам забороняли: починаючи від абетки, далі - театр, книга, бібліотека.
Здавалося, що ми вже не встигнемо на той потяг, який веде до цілісної,
красивої, політичної, європейської нації,
а ми встигли за ці 30 років і зараз демонструємо…
Ну ви ж відчуваєте, що нами пишається весь світ?
Нам аплодують ті, які, можливо, ще 15-20 років тому не дозволяли
говорити якісь комплементарні слова.
У нас справді колосально відбувся позитивний процес, коли ми…
Я не хочу казати це слово - "квазінація",
але по деяких питаннях ми вже квазі були.
Сьогодні ми прийшли до цілісної, гарної, європейської, політичної нації.
Друге - те, що сьогодні скаже будь-яка пересічна людина -
нашим солдатом і нашою солдаткою.
Запитайте в Європі будь-якого політика.
Чи запитайте в США будь-якого політика,
особливого близького до військової справи,
вони скажуть, що український генерал, український солдат і солдатка заслуговують тільки оплесків.
Яка армія в Європі може так багатофункціонально використовувати арсенал озброєння, як українська?
Жодна.
Український солдат найцікавіший, наймужніший,
стратегічно й тактично найкраще озброєний.
І перший параграф, з якого я почав відповідати, і другий параграф - присвячений військовим.
Нас привели до того, що ми відчули, що ми володіємо такою величчю духу,
що нам цей Путін нестрашний, нам ці орки нестрашні.
Ми переконані, що ми їх переможемо.
Ніхто в цьому сумніву не має,
і врешті-решт ми прийшли до політичного розуміння,
що сьогодні головний дипломат у нас - солдат.
І кожна його поведінка, оцінка, думка про те, як повинна Україна
рухатися в цій московській війні, є базова й фундаментальна.
Чому на серці спокійно?
Тому що нема в світі сили, яка б українському солдату
сказала: "Слухай, може, кидай ту шинель, кидай той автомат чи БТР
і давай сідати за стіл перемовин".
Ні, такого добра, такого акценту наш солдат не дасть.
Однією з найчутливіших суспільних тем й досі залишається мова.
Яку стратегію має обрати держава, аби більше українців розмовляли українською?
Нація починається з мови. Це суть національного.
Мова - це вмістилище нашого духу. Наша рідна мова.
Якщо ми з розумом підходимо до цього питання,
то ми повинні прагнути до формування і реалізації тої мовної політики,
яка процвітає сьогодні в кожного із наших сусідів, усіх європейських сусідів.
Тому українська мова - це наш кордон.
Якщо ми будемо цільними, і в базі цієї цілісності буде стояти наша мова,
наша культура, наша пам’ять, наша історія, наші герої -
ми будем такими, як поляки.
Із жодного боку їх не розпиляти. Ні географія їх не руйнує,
ні національні герої, ні пам’ять, ні бібліотеки, ні музеї, ні мова,
тому що вони цільна нація.
Це не політика одного дня, це не політика-одноходівка.
Очевидно, її треба проводити коректно, тактовно,
поважаючи кожну людину, бо це тонкий лід.
Але я зараз підкреслюю те, що напрямок цієї політики очевидний.
Давайте повернемося у 2005 рік, коли ви стали президентом.
Незалежній Україні тоді було лише 14 років.
Багато українців тоді дивилися російські серіали, не знали війни
й приймали своє перше "Євробачення".
Коли ви озираєтеся назад на той час, що вам здається найважчим?
Найважчим було становище після 14 років проросійської,
або я навіть сказав би, що російської політики,
яку проводила або постійно, або час від часу Україна.
Ви пам’ятаєте ту атмосферу, яка з'явилася в значній частині суспільства,
мовляв, цієї політики вже досить.
Ми повинні по-тихеньку, по-тихеньку змінювати орієнтири
і переходити на політику європейської інтеграції,
ми повинні переоцінити своє відношення до свобод, до демократії.
Таким чином ми підходили до виборів у жовтні 2004 року,
що це останній шанс, який в України є:
або ми зливаємося з Росією, як Білорусь, як країни Центральної Азії,
або ми врешті-решт повертаємося додому, до тої політики, яка завжди була притаманна українській державі:
чи часів Русі, чи козацтва, чи державам, які ми утворювали у ХХ ст.
І я вважав, що 2004 рік - це та точка, коли ми ще встигаємо повернутися додому,
або якщо ми програємо 2004 рік, ми програємо надовго.
Принаймні на декілька поколінь,
тому що Росія з тою політикою, яку вона почала проводити в Європі,
фінансово мужніла з року в рік.
Корупція, з якою Росія проводила політику, особливо в Західній Європі,
привела до того, що сьогодні практично в кожному національному парламенті Європи
є сили, які будуть ще довго боротися за Росію,
за російську присутність у Європі, за російські відносини.
Готуючись до інтерв'ю, я запитала своїх друзів, колег, батьків:
чим їм запам'яталося ваше президентство?
І найперші асоціації з вами - патріотизм, популяризація української мови, відродження національної пам'яті.
Водночас серед нарікань - повільне впровадження реформ,
потужний запит на які був після Помаранчевої революції.
Чи вважаєте ви, що досягнення Помаранчевої революції було провалено?
В жодному випадку. Можна почати з того, що у 2005 році
була проведена конституційна реформа.
З цього часу Україна стала парламентською державою.
Тобто державою, в якій формування уряду належить парламенту,
вибори прем'єра належать парламенту,
вибори кожного міністра належать парламенту.
До 2005 року це була функція президента.
Якщо ми говоримо про економічну політику, про політику свобод і демократії, військову політику -
це все елементи парламентської політики України.
До сьогоднішнього дня. Наприклад, реформа суду.
Перший, хто в Україні зробив концепцію реформи суду, -
це та комісія, яку я призначив на чолі з Сергієм Головатим.
Концепція була зроблена, подана в парламент, і що?
Я вам нагадаю: український парламент 2005 року - це парламент,
який по естафеті ми прийняли від періоду Леоніда Кучми.
Очолював парламент Литвин, більшість була з регіоналами, комуністами і так далі.
От скажіть, будь ласка, що можна в такому парламенті провести?
Нічого, нічого не проведеш.
Бо з тою філософією, з якою йшов у 2004 році, у 2005 році у стінах парламенту це антитеза була.
Навпаки ми виступали проти їхньої політики,
але за Конституцією вони могли ще півтора роки знаходитися в парламенті.
Приходить наступний 2006 рік, провели перед літом вибори,
які восени закріпилися у новому парламенті.
Ситуація в новому парламенті: в мене було 72 голоси.
От мені цікаво подивитися, як би будь-хто із президентів, у якого були 72 голоси у парламенті своєї політичної сили,
провели реформи президента Ющенка.
Цікаво б мені подивитися було.
Україна 2005-2010 років - це Україна, яка отримала найбільше, наприклад, інвестицій, більше 35 млрд.
У нас кожен місяць один млрд інвестицій приносив.
Я скажу, що загально і питання національної розбудови,
і питання європейської інтеграції,
і питання нової моделі колективної безпеки й членство в НАТО,
і економічний підйом, який був найкращий за наші роки незалежності.
По економічних темпах ми не опускалися нижче 7% динаміки валового продукту.
У нас були квартали, де було до 12% приріст валового продукту.
Давайте ще один раз повторим таке!
Я б сказав, знаєте, не треба легковажним судом судити.
Я думаю, що ми пройшли 2005-2010 роки у варіанті,
який не повинні піддавати дуже гірким висновкам.
Вшанування пам’яті жертв Голодомору нині стало націєтворчим і об'єднуючим наративом.
А яким було сприйняття цієї трагедії в Україні в той час,
коли ви стали президентом?
Дуже цікаве питання. Дуже цікаве.
У нас кожне покоління мріяло мати незалежну Україну.
Приходить ХХ ст., дуже трагічне для України.
Ми найбільше в Європі втратили людей, 10 млн на фронтах Другої світової війни,
10 млн у 1932-1933 роках і ще 5 млн у 1920-их і 1940-их роках.
Ну яка нація таку трагедію може пережити?
Українська.
І тому, коли ми говорили з 2005 року:
"Знаєте, ви повинні пишатися своїми дідами, своїми бабусями,
які навіть у ХХ ст. пережили одні з найбільших трагедій, які торкались нашої землі.
І якщо ви їх не пам'ятаєте, якщо ви не шануєте їхнє життя та їхню смерть,
бо я думаю, що до останньої секунди вони думали про вас,
онуків і правнуків, вони сподівалися, що завтра буде те життя, про яке ми мріяли.
І тому, коли я проголосив одним із питань нашої національної політики:
"Давайте ми дамо належну оцінку цим трагедіям.
Адже якщо ми підійдемо до чесної, науково-обґрунтованої й правильної оцінки,
насправді ми додамо собі ще пару крил, які піднімуть українську націю".
Ми почали зі шкіл, ніби силами школи встигнути зафіксувати свідчення,
бо вже тоді 75 років пройшло з дня Великого голоду,
з днів голоду 1920-их років майже не було свідків.
З 1932-1933 цих свідків ще можна було знайти.
У книгу національної пам'яті за три роки ми дописали півтора мільйона людей.
Здавалося б, на сьогодні ця тема глибоко вивчена,
ми розуміємося на її причинах і витоках, злочинцях, які робили цей голод.
І постало питання, звісно, що це російська політика,
московська політика геноциду української нації.
Слово "українська" в цьому визначенні ключове,
бо інші нації знали голод,
але голод ціленаправленого вбивства як спосіб знала тільки українська нація.
Я до сьогоднішнього дня до якоїсь міри трагічно й драматично згадую той день,
коли в парламенті було голосування.
Ми перемогли в парламенті.
Ви знаєте, що більшість в українському парламенті - 226 голосів,
половина від 450,
а за "голод-геноцид в Україні 1932-1933 років" проголосували 227 нардепів.
Оце відповідь на те, з чого ми починали.
Бо багато людей думали, що це політика, що президенту нема чим зайнятися,
то давайте згадаємо дідів-прадідів.
А що ви думаєте про будівництво музею Голодомору?
Адже є українці, які не підтримують цю ідею, мовляв, не на часі, гроші мають йти на армію, а не на музеї.
Ви бачите, що останні два роки там консервація, там великого руху ви не побачите.
Ми в громадському фонді, який забезпечує фінансування різних конкурсів,
різних потреб в організації цього музею, як ви розумієте,
ми працюємо винятково на громадські пожертви.
Там немає жодної копійки, яка би була взята від воїна,
від фронту й направлена була б на цей музей.
У цьому році, коли почалася абсолютно правильна дискусія:
чи треба нам зараз золотити купола Софії?
Думаю, два сезони до перемоги ми почекаємо.
Можемо почекати, якби нашим солдатам, солдаткам дали те, що їм потрібно для перемоги над московитами.
Те саме стосується й Музею Голодомору, те саме стосується й будівництва доріг і так далі.
Сьогодні головне питання - дати відповідь, що Україна вічна,
що ми перемагаємо, а через фінансовий рік ми знайдемо на Софію кошти,
на те, як добудувати Музей Голодомору.
Я думаю, що до тих великих дат пам'яті ми все зробимо,
щоб культурницька сторона українського питання була підведена у високій якості.
Переконаний, що ми встигнемо все зробити. Після перемоги.
За вашої каденції були знищені останні десять бомбардувальників, які належали Україні.
Поясніть, у чому була необхідність цієї утилізації?
Чи була можливість зберегти ці бомбардувальники?
Хм, підступне питання.
У вересні я дивилася інтерв'ю Буданова, можливо, ви теж бачили. Він про це згадував.
Я одразу після того інтерв'ю передзвонив ексміністру оборони Юрію Єханурову,
щоб він нагадав мені відповідь.
Президент жодного розпорядження про знищення не писав. Це очевидно.
По-друге, яка історія цього питання?
Міністр оборони мені відповів, що в 1994 році після завершення Будапештського саміту,
після підписання меморандуму про передачу ядерної зброї
невід'ємною частиною цього міжнародного документу
щодо стратегічних бомбардувальників було:
або передача їх РФ, або розборка цих літаків в Україні.
І тоді було ухвалено рішення, що якась їхня частина у 1994 році була передана Росії,
а ці десять апаратів, про які ви говорите, - це останнє знищення.
Очевидно, що тоді Міністерство оборони підійшло з розумінням,
що передавати ці апарати Росії політично недоцільно,
щоб виконати міжнародні зобов'язання, їх треба розібрати в Україні.
Це стратегічні бомбардувальники, які були в рамках міжнародних зобов'язань розібрані.
Це ті зобов'язання, які повинна була виконати Україна.
Ми домовилися, що ми відправляємо письмове свідчення Москві, письмове свідчення про те,
що ми хотіли б, щоб із Севастополя відповідно до попередньої міжнародної угоди
російський флот був виведений до 2017 року.
Ви розумієте, з якою "радістю" Росія це зустріла,
почала аргументувати, що вони не встигають за 10 років модернізувати
новоросійський порт чи будь-який інший,
що їм треба 20-30-40 років для цього.
Ми відповіли повторно, що ніякої ревізії договору про розміщення російського флоту не буде.
Після 2017 року жодного російського корабля чи будь-якого іншого плавзасобу не повинно бути в Україні.
Тоді зібрали п'ять головних конструкторських бюро,
які займалися військовою тематикою,
вони й до сьогоднішнього дня займаються.
Розуміючи, до яких іспитів нам треба готуватися, маючи за плечима острів Тузла.
Той конфлікт, який при президентові Леоніді Кучмі,
ми вже тоді відчули, що ось-ось вони поряд,
що насипають дамбу, залишилось кілька сотень метрів до Керчі.
Керченський міст - це улюблена цяцька Путіна.
Ми розуміли, що це велика загроза для України.
Було виділено фінанси, які породили розробки,
які потім нас привели до танку "Оплот", одного з кращих у цій серії,
потім до різних систем протиповітряних і протиракетних - "Вільха", "Стугна".
У нас були розробки по стрілецькій зброї, по пістолетах,
які взяті на озброєння, у нас були "Нептуни".
Словом, це те дихання, з якого ми хотіли розпочати нову військову доктрину
в рамках зближення з системою колективної безпеки Європи, панатлантичною,
щоб у нас з'явилися арсенали, які були б достойні викликам того часу.
Що загалом заважало розбудовувати й укріплювати українську армію за вашої каденції?
У нас тоді великі конфлікти з урядом були.
По військовому бюджету я кілька разів офіційно говорив про те,
що якщо не буде задоволено армійський бюджет,
якщо не буде задоволено цифри, які міністерство оборони
подавало як проєкт міністерства фінансів і уряду в цілому,
я на такий бюджет накладу вето, я його не підпишу.
І в нас двічі такий механізм - винятково по системі міноборони - переглядався,
відправляли на доопрацювання, й українській армії додавали фінансування належне.
На вашу думку, чи буде врешті-решт Україна в НАТО?
Нема питань. Ми як ніколи близько підійшли до розуміння,
чому корисна для європейського проєкту колективної безпеки Україна,
що сьогодні Україна воює, як одна з найкращих армій НАТО.
Із високим класом і практично з будь-якою технікою,
яка виробляється чи в Британії, чи в Німеччині, чи у Франції, чи в Америці.
Словом, це одна з найпрофесійніших армій, яка боронить сьогодні не тільки Україну,
а й світ від російської окупації.
Я переконаний, що Україна здобуде перемогу, що Росія буде переможена.
Дуже важливо не замикатися тільки на українській частині перемоги, а дослухатися далі.
Бо якщо Росія залишиться такою путінською, як є сьогодні,
то це нещастя для всього світу.
І тоді, будь ласка, не запитуйте, по кому дзвонить дзвін?
По всіх вас. Такої Росії не повинно бути.
І тому після української перемоги, коли ми повертаємо всі материнські землі
й коли закінчуємо ті дев'ять інших пунктів "мирного плану" президента Зеленського,
ми переходимо до другої частини нашої перемоги -
це те, як разом із світом зробити, щоб політики сьогоднішньої Росії не було.
Після нашої перемоги безумовно постане питання шансу Росії.
Я думаю, що ми повинні дати шанс корінним народам Росії.
Я переконаний, що Татарстан давно вже має проєкт національного визволення,
що Башкортостан має проєкт національного визволення.
Тим більше країні, багатій ресурсами, перш за все, енергетичними.
Я думаю, що цього заслуговує Дагестан, Ічкерія, Інгушетія
й багато інших національних територій, у яких збережена національна пам'ять,
у яких є національна мова, релігія.
Іншими словами, всіх, хто забажає у цій тюрмі народів стати вільними,
наш обов'язок - підтримати це стремління.
Як гадаєте, після всіх злочинів, які Росія вчинила й продовжує вчиняти зараз,
чи можливе в перспективі історичне примирення?
У моїй моделі Росії немає такої.
Я уточню свою позицію: тут питання не в Путіні.
Сьогодні можна говорити, що носієм путінізму є не тільки Путін,
а є 140 млн оцих маленьких путіних.
Навіть якщо будуть проведені у Росії вільні вибори,
я не думаю, що буде досягнуто ту ціль, яка приведе до спокою наших відносин.
Не вірю в це.
Ви багато репортажів бачите з Росії, де можете створити образ пересічного росіянина.
Йому свободи не потрібно, це не є його потреба, йому демократії не потрібні.
Єдине, що почне його тривожити й вести у великий гнів -
якщо почне дорожчати горілка чи тютюн в Росії.
Це дві причини для бунта.
І коли ми будемо говорити, а за кого будуть голосувати після Путіна?
За Путіна.
Бо він створив цілу спільноту, яка ще багато років
буде приймати путінську політику як краще з того, що вони знають.
Так або інакше війна торкнулася майже кожного в Україні.
Чи є зараз на фронті хтось дорогий вашому серцю?
Кожен солдат.
Пару тижнів тому я звернувся в поліклініку.
І поряд із реанімаційною палатою була одна палата, де лежав наш солдат.
Я медсестрам сказав, що хочу зайти до нашого козака.
Я зайшов і бачу, знаєте, такий великий символ, таку велику картину:
лежить молодий хлопчина, думаю, років 20-22,
лівої руки немає, правої руки немає, культя якась, правого ока немає, обличчя посічене уламками.
Цей солдат звертається до мене й каже: "Пане президенте,
оце ж дивіться: оця рука в мене буде, ця теж буде працювати. Око.
Ви гляньте, в мене було два ока, тепер - одне. Так я й з одним буду жити".
У нього дух був такий, знаєте, що ті слова, які варто було б говорити комусь, хто зайшов, але він сам їх говорив.
Мовляв, оці всі, хто тут стоїть, майте на увазі, що в мене така сила, я такий козак.
Усе це дуже пече, за це дуже щемить.
Як бачу солдата, чи в магазині, чи десь на вулиці, чи в аеропорту, чи на вокзалі,
перше, що хочеться, і я це роблю, підходжу, обіймаю й кажу:
"Ти знаєш, що ти найкращий?"
А він каже: "Знаю, мені сьогодні вже казали".
Так, слава їм! Слава їм!
Дякую вам за цю розмову!
Дякую вам!